el primer Campeonato del mundo en tres
países Estados Unidos Canadá y México
sobre los desafíos organizativos de ese
torneo conversamos con Eduardo vizcayar
quien se encuentra en doha y desde allá
nos comentó su visión bueno los desafíos
organizativos del próximo mundial
son más que nada no en el tema de la
infraestructura que está prácticamente
toda hecha salvo algún retoque quizá
sobre todo del lado canadiense que
entendemos por la capacidad organizativa
de los canadienses esto no Debería ser
un problema Entonces creo que los
estadios están casi todos
necesitan retoques Estados Unidos es uno
de esos pocos de los pocos países que
puede organizar un mundial digamos en un
breve lapso de tiempo y esa es la gran
ventaja que tiene porque sus estadios
son Realmente fantásticos la gran
mayoría y donde se albergan espectáculos
como los que hoy presentó o como los que
ha presentado este mundial
en Qatar ya casi semana a semana cuando
se juega la temporada de la NFL las
distancias van a ser un problema Eso sí
porque estamos hablando de un país muy
vasto muy amplio vamos a hablar de tres
países también y eso creo que puede
llegar a ser el punto más importante
se compite en el verano también y hay
ciertas partes en el país como Kansas
que pueden llegar a tener ciertas
amenazas de tormentas eléctricas
tornados etcétera que pueden llegar a
afectar pero en cuanto al aspecto de los
estadios y en cuanto al aspecto de la
logística Más allá de las distancias no
debería haber problemas
habéis callar también le consultamos
sobre el aspecto deportivo Más allá de
lo organizativo y en lo que se refiere
al desarrollo futbolístico Cómo se ven
las cosas para estos tres equipos de la
Concacaf esto nos dijo
Bueno yo creo que el tema de la
preparación de cada uno de los
seleccionados
va a traer un yo creo que una cierta
preparación fina porque Ninguno de los
tres países anfitriones de acuerdo a la
planificación que se entiende al día de
hoy en ninguno va a tener que pasar por
un proceso de clasificación creo que el
que mejor mundial ha hecho aquí es
Estados Unidos y Estados Unidos que no
había estado en el mundial de Rusia 2018
es un equipo que trabajó para
recuperarse y lo ha conseguido bastante
bien quizá necesite Ese es el debate
otro entrenador Más allá de halter quizá
dentro de la tradición de los tres
equipos el Que aparezca como más
perjudicado con más terreno para ganar o
para recuperarse a la selección mexicana
y si México tiene las cosas mucho más
difíciles porque pese a tener una liga
muy competitiva pese a tener un fútbol
muy competitivo con mucha tradición en
mundiales más allá que sus anfitriones
México necesita un entrenador necesita
un buen entrenador pero pero sobre todo
necesita entender cómo tienen que ser
sus torneos pacificar un poco todo el
ámbito local porque la prensa suele
llegar a ser muy dura y si se quiere muy
agresiva en el medio mexicano y Canadá
ha regresado a un mundial aquí no pudo
no estuvo la altura de competir de
acuerdo a los resultados pero me parece
que dejó una buena imagen en cuanto a
jugadores a futuro y en cuanto a esa
distancia que va acortando o que ha
demostrado que pudo acortar para
clasificarse para este mundial yo le
auguro a Canadá un buen un buen futuro y
dicen por allí que su entrenador para el
próximo mundial podría llegar a ser
Carlo ancelotti que reside justamente
parte del tiempo en Canadá dicen que
cuando deja el Real Madrid sería Carlos
ancelotti Porque la esposa de Carlos
ancelotti es canadiense